dea
今から日本語のレッスンを行います
外人ハンター外人ハンターとは単純に言うと外国人が好きな日本人のこと
日本には外人版たが非常に多い
らしいなんかこうしてみよう僕が日本で知らない日本人女性に話しかけられた数は
いくらだと思う
はいゼロです一度もないです一方北アメリカで日本人女性に話しかけられた数
これも一度もないですじゃあ僕がアメリカで白人女性に話しかけられた数はいくらだと
思う
ゼロですなぁ
ラバーがアメリカで知らない白人男性に話しかけられて数はいくらだと思う
ゼロです
何を8としたっけ
me
んだアイスコーヒーお願いしますあーちょっと待ってくださいすぐに英語ができる
スタッフを呼びしますマフィア日本語で話してますけど
iso アーレ p pou dou dou
コーヒー02分オーバー miitan d 相撲ちゃぱにーず会が昨日3つマイ
プレイスインサイ aim ステー2
アイスコーヒーをお願いしますよっぱねぇ違うスプーンの恋今日本語で話しましたよね
なにアナとは英語で返事をしました阿蘇渇水しますこれは問題ですね僕は英語ができ
なかってはどうしますかこれはさあ別なんですよ人種差別なんですよ
マネージャー選んでください僕の日本語あなたの英語より調査
ですうん
アイスコーヒーをお願いします店の中で飲みますか
ん
アイスコーヒーお願いしますアイスコーヒーですね店内でお召し上がりですか
そうですかしこまりました350円です
今日は在留カードの更新したいんですけどパスポートと住所が記載されているものを
持参してください
あと更新の申請書も出してくださいねうん
paas 型浅い
ッパ今日は身元保証将来に来たんですけど入っまず
目薬をもらってきてくださいめぐ3ですかこの処方箋を東准将の方に渡してください
大
わかりましたね
あ今日はここに来たら目薬もらえるって聞いたんですけどそれの原料ならここにあり
ますけどあり夜行の赤瀬にこれを足してくださいこれは親善の家に届けない
これは目玉が l ではないか
今夜は久しぶりに寝だめエクセリトナー
さあできたしかしこの温度ではこの薬を
しみる頃
true
はいえっとどう幻想
お待たせしました
また1年間化やふう